the Joe Rogan experience but when you
see like a campus eruption at Yale over
you know the Halloween costumes business
yeah Nicholas Christakis you know I mean
that you know we all looked at that went
oh my god this is ridiculous but in a
way it's a sign of progress like the
students in the sixties used to you know
protest the Vietnam War or you know the
way blacks were treated in the south
those are you know those are really
legitimate things to complain about
protest about but there there aren't as
many of those around anymore for
students to get all riled up about and
they still have those moral impulses
like I want to promote what's right and
I want to be against evil and I'm all
fired up here with my my moral module
dialed up to 11 I'm going to go out on
the streets what am I going to protest
those Halloween costumes
you know people that cultural
appropriation you know and so on
remember there was a tell the story in a
book about this Taco Tuesday at Cal
State Fullerton I was invited to give a
speech there years ago about protecting
free speech over this issue that caused
the campus to just erupt and in protest
about Taco Tuesday it's like Taco
Tuesday yeah that's cultural
appropriation you know the Mexican
community is being appropriated by these
whites eating tacos like we're in
Southern California where is there no
tacos I mean this is you know the guy
who tried to patent Taco Tuesday LeBron
James LeBron J did a Jamie isn't that
what happened yeah he talks about Taco
Tuesday on his Instagram I was on his
Instagram and he's like you know what
today is and then he shows his talk Taco
Tuesday you know okay what is he allowed
to do it I mean the whole thing is
preposterous it's delicious food you
know it's not like we're saying that you
know white people created it or anything
like that I mean and cultural
appropriation is so ridiculous in so
many ways but one of the most ridiculous
ways it is is that it prevents people
from enjoying some amazing aspects of
the diverse cultures that we all coexist
with especially here in America I mean
this is such a legitimate melting pot I
think it's amazing that you can go to
all these different places and that you
know there's a guy
I'm trying to remember his name Rick
Bayless I believe his name is and he's a
famous Mexican chef but he's not Mexican
but he cooks Mexican food and he loves
Mexican cuisine he takes all these trips
to Mexico to learn with the Mexican
masters and he has a famous restaurant
in Chicago where he has a full authentic
Mexican menu and people were furious at
him because here is this white guy
selling Mexican food like what do you
expect him to do like do you have to be
born a certain patch of dirt to enjoy a
style of food and don't you think that
he is actually boosting the signal and
letting people know that there's some
amazing things that come out of Mexico
this is an homage to Mexican cuisine
he's not trying to claim it but you know
hey this was invented in Chicago you
know this is not really Mexican no he's
he's saying this is from Mexico he talks
openly about the various parts of the
country of Mexico where this style of
cooking came from and and you know and
how it emanates and from the the
traditional ingredients and he cooks
them in traditional ways and fantastic
like really widely praised restaurant
with amazing food and this guy gets [ __ ]
on for it it's it's crazy this is not
only these perverse reversals because it
used to be like in the 19th century
there was this idea of kind of a pure
European culture and other cultures were
somehow not as good and they defined
culture in a very specific way and and
then you know kind of liberals but then
we're pushing back against that say no
no you know the cultures are equal and
culture is a whole blend of of different
you know migrations and people mixing
and that's what culture that's what
makes cultural rich it's yes it's fluid
and changing and so on and now all of a
sudden liberals are saying no no there's
a pure correct culture that only the
people born there can use you know it
adopt those cultural features that's the
complete opposite of what liberals used
to argue yes
starting with anthropologists say no no
no there's this crazy idea that whites
and whites a from mrs. heaven I'd you or
a European cultures bunch of nonsense
Europeans are just as amalgamated with
lots of different cultures as anybody
else
there is no
European culture yeah it's it's a weird
time and I again I connect this to the
fact that we didn't have as many real
problems as we used to and when you talk
about Yale with Nic or stockist I think
there's this thing that kids do when
they're coming of age they're separated
from their parents and they want to
establish that so many of these older
people were wrong about the way life is
and they're wrong we're gonna show them
what's right and we have a new way of
living we have a new way of thinking and
we want this campus to be safe we want
safe spaces and a lot of it is about
taking control of their environment and
enforcing their ideology and creating
something that's in a lot of ways is
very ego driven because they're trying
to show that they're making a change in
the environment around them and they
have good intentions while they're doing
it it's just their brains haven't fully
formed yet and they don't have a lot of
life experience and this pattern this
pattern shows itself over and over and
over again it's a constantly repeating
pattern where these kids go away to
college and become self righteous and
then try to impose their viewpoints on
the older people it's very very common
and it has this these psychological
building blocks to it that you can kind
of see why they're doing this
[Applause]